it's more fun if you're in the air right
i think so
wait what are we talking about hey guys
travis pastrana here lindsay adams
hawkins pastrana
and this is stuff support
[Music]
all right first question from chase
barrett almost good 0707
watching your old nascar xfinity race
and it made me wonder if you
ever raced dirt late models think you'd
be good at it
i found out i'm not very good at things
unless everyone is
scared so like video games nope
everybody kicks my butt nascar safer
barriers no one's really afraid to hit
the wall even though you're going 200
miles an hour and everyone should be
rally 100 foot vertical cliff on the
outside snow
at night sideways making the best of the
worst conditions
that's kind of what i do i did okay on
on tarmac
i guess i won the better half dash
lindsay's the only one that's won a
nascar race and yeah she's probably
better on payment she likes kind of
getting to that edge and not going over
it
where i do better going over the edge
but
yes i have tried dirt late models good
sure good compared to kyle busch
no at landing castle has the check mark
is a badass by the way so
professional nascar driver travis
estrada why do you make everything a ram
what do you think do you like flying
yeah like flying i like jumping stuff
actually fun fact i met lindsay because
she was the only female skateboarder
that could actually hit the gigana ramp
it's just over six stories tall biggest
thing is actually to just run
stairs because you have to run up and
then drop it
sprint up drop in so many people they
hit the bottom of the ramp and their
legs completely just turned to
jello they just buckle it's like when
you get double bounced on a trampoline
you have to be able to
withstand that so when you're in a show
and you're running up six floors at a
time
20 25 times in a show and your legs give
out
you look silly she doesn't do that no i
train stairs
yeah she likes to fly that's why we
ended up together
landon uh everything has to be a ramp
because everything is more fun if it
flies
right yeah julia a julie underscore a
undercover underscore peace sign she
asked
what is the scariest trick to perform
for myself yeah well i guess probably
backflip the
gigano ramp just kind of scary to go
upside down sometimes
the first scariest trick i ever did
i guess just dropping in a root ramp i
was little i was maybe 11
and i just stood up there all day with
my board on the edge of the ramp
yo i'm gonna do it no i'm not gonna do
it no i'm gonna do it all day all day so
finally my brother
and his buddies sean white they came
behind me and they pushed me
and i like jumped in and i knee slid and
i was totally fine but i got that
gut feeling of dropping and was like oh
that's the worst that can happen so i
ran up
dropped in insert career for me the
scariest trick is anything you're not
prepared for
it doesn't really matter what the trick
is like when you first start doing
superman seat crabs that's the scariest
thing and now they're doing double
backflips with superman secrets so
the impossible is an ever moving
boundary
what's the scariest trick today is going
to be something you warm up with
tomorrow
this one is a serious question you
should probably read that one adam
tanal a channel 20. serious question
how does one break into the stunt driver
business
almost all of my friends are stunt
drivers it's a little different skill
set
than racing but generally if you're top
in your sport
it's a lot easier to get into that world
and you don't have to be
necessarily the best in the world at
speed but you have to have
really really good car control so most
of your top drivers will have
a lot of experience out of control and
trying to figure out how to make the
best of all vehicles so the easiest way
to get into stunts
is to do really well at racing and
driving cars and then
they call you first and then go down the
list kevin at uh
kevin blasis nitro circus chassis china
how do i join the team you know nitro
because we're like a family
your overall person and being
plays a big part in it when you're on
your fifth show in the fifth country and
you wake up and everyone's tired
you need to be the person that wakes up
and rallies everyone and it's like all
right yeah let's do it
there's two ways to join nitro circus
one be better than
everyone else in the world two be
willing to do something that no one else
in the world is willing to do
i seriously say yes the first because
the second one is more painful right
or somehow get me to see your video and
send it to nitro we got a lot of people
in that way
a-rod douchebag 1776.
travis was shot my buddy thinks you can
backflip off this tiny pile of dirt
i say no can you prove either of us
right well
if you say you're going to do something
you have to do it so that's a
kind of the foundation of nitro circus
so i'm looking at this pile of dirt and
i think in general
i can backflip about anything
but i think i would probably get the
flip around land on the front tire and
belly flop
so successfully no
die well you go upside down probably
yeah oh definitely upside down yeah
yeah no i wouldn't want to but you know
it could be done
okay tony face
caleb morris 17. imagine being
quarantined in travis pastrana's
backyard
well i'm here to tell you i've done it
being able to spend time as a family and
not have so many people around like
we're used to
it was awesome we were able to swim and
skate and drive and and moto our kids
got into moto which was
huge for us it was so cute on their
little 50s all pink
moto and cute have never gone together
in the sentence so seamlessly whatever
step at retro set how can i drive ride
passenger to wrc car
asking for me which is funny because
usually they're like yeah asking for a
friend
the only time i ever got to drive a wrc
car or go passenger i was actually 17
years old i won the u.s championship and
my sponsor alpine star
said you know what if you win the
championship i know you love cars we're
going to get you
a drive i thought it was just passenger
in a wrc car so i went out in richard
burns
factory like three-quarter million
dollar car at 17 years old and
i just went ham on it and destroyed
actually not the car but i went by the
semi-rig and just pelted it with rocks
and evidently somehow that made a good
impression because they decided to
kind of keep me under the subaru wing
and for me i got to answer your question
having sponsors in motocross allowed me
to transfer over to that
and that's the last time i ever got to
drive a wrc car so maybe i didn't do a
good job
greta smith at g2 loretta serious
question
how do motocrossers not hurt their balls
during all the jumps um i mean
stand up we do we do
um as it turns out most of us tend to
have one or the other that we hurt more
often
for whatever reason i think is when you
do a double backflip you tend to land on
the front of the motorcycle and smash
we have one enlarged uh testicle it's
actually from landing on the gas tank
so hard and usually tucked to either
right or left so
one stays stays nice and uh we have two
beautiful little girls so clearly they
still work right at least one
paul mccaffrey calf man yolo
why hasn't anybody ever done a base jump
dressed as wiley coyote
this would be epic we agree
he's not going to do it and the reason
he kind of banned him from base jumping
because now we have kids and he needs to
like
stick around base jumping is probably
the most
dangerous uh sport if you will because
the first time you step off a cliff
if anything goes wrong you don't have
enough time to correct it and that's why
there's so many deaths
the reason that no one is dressed as
wildly coyote is because
whenever he straps himself to an acme
rocket or whatever he's doing it never
works out well for the coyote
so but it would still be funny yeah
germs
stay golden 91 what if buster keaton
evel knievel johnny knoxville and myself
all hung out
i've hung out with evel knievel i've
hung out with johnny knoxville i've
never hung out with buster keaton
at this point like later in our lives i
think we'd all just
sit around telling really amazing
stories if we did it
younger in our lives i think that would
have been the last day that we got to
hung out
hung out could have done something
really sketchy everett's
71 asks can you backflip a yz-490 travis
i would say yes and i have proved it so
i had the opportunity
um to actually yes i got it
all right i backflipped a yz490 at fight
club
so p1k brand new anime at
dillon one kenobi hey travis china want
to give stock cars another try
a lot of cool stuff is happening in
iracing during the quarantine
winky face what did you think of stock
car racing i actually kind of enjoyed
going to nascar
everybody except for you thought that
you did great
but if you're not winning then you're
not winning it was an awesome time it
was a great experience during the
quarantine got to really
meet up with a lot of the indy car
drivers and the wrc drivers and nascar
guys and rally guys and everybody came
together
and raced and it was awesome i miss the
racing aspect uh but
pavement's just not my thing i mean i
wish it was it's fun
but i'm not very good kirk bells at
fall kirk bells
question is my daughter would like a bmx
style bike for christmas she wants to
learn
how to do stunts i don't know where to
start any advice or recommended
shocks to try thanks it depends on how
old your daughter is and her size
because there are a lot of different
bikes out there
there's 12 inch 14 inch 16 18 and then a
20 inch bike
is what a normal adult would ride if you
start with the spawn bikes
they're built really well there's all
different sizes if you get really into
bmx
hyper makes the absolute best
kids lightweight bmx bike
it's really expensive i wouldn't
recommend starting there if your dog is
really young the cult juvenile they make
it the 12-inch one is
is really tiny you know you want to
start with a balanced bicycle
you can get them riding some hills or
some pump tracks something like that
start there at that point you have some
control and understanding of what the
bike's going to do
i guess you got to start with size of
your kid and then go from there
christopher manning christo 8769-4284
travis channel what about a hoverboard
can it be done
so yes actually working with uh red bull
i was a little heavy for the first one
that they came out with
it really wouldn't lift off the ground
much with me but yeah it could be done
unfortunately i don't do boards so we'd
have to yeah
what do you think hoverboard to flip it
or jump it or
all the things it just says what about a
hoverboard yeah all the things on nitro
circus
if you ride it you jump it sensible
power add sensible power
i want to learn how to drive on two
wheels simple ride a bicycle
uh okay also um if you're trying to
drive on two wheels in a four-wheel
vehicle
i'd say you start with a like a can-am
or a side-by-side
and you get a set of yokohama super
diggers they are a bias fly tire
um which means they kind of roll over so
it gives you a little bit
more grip inflate them way more than you
think you'll need to
because that whole weight of the vehicle
will be on the side of the tire and you
just kind of go in a corner and you
start turning you got to have a big
open area and you turn stay the same
speed turn
sharper sharper sharper and the second
it starts to come off
turn back the other way so you start
doing that and if you spend a day
going around in circles you will
eventually figure out how to get up on
two wheels and how does that feel
well you know it feels really sideways
daryl dropped her
redford at drafter underscore so i found
myself doing a lot of right foot braking
but when i watch sim racers i see a
majority of left foot braking
is it something i need to work on or
does it not really matter darrell
when you're driving a rally car it is
absolutely mandatory anything off-road
anything where you're starting to slide
around you need weight on the front
wheels
to be able to make the vehicle turn if
you're going for the absolute
maximum quickest time left foot braking
is the way to go
uh because you can keep the car balanced
in the corner especially if you're
sliding and you're going off-road you
have to learn how to do that
derrick b at oh underscore dion
i just want to learn how to do a proper
j-turn before i die what i would
recommend for learning is you go into a
parking lot
you go as fast as the vehicle go in
reverse and you crank the wheel as hard
as you can
now here's the key when you crank the
wheel it's going to start sliding
you have to go into drive make sure
you're in
a gear that's fast enough to continue
accelerating you out of that
done deal you look like a hero miguel at
the miguel castro how do i get into red
bull stunt driver like when they have a
demonstration or
filming or video how do i get into that
not even just trying to be sponsored
i just want to do some awesome stunts
for redbull and an f1 car the chance of
anyone driving an f1 car that isn't one
of the best drivers in the world
um is very very slim having said that
the biggest thing about trying to be a
stunt driver is don't
do it on the streets has to be a close
course everyone says i was 18 once
you know when you went out there and you
thought you were better than you were
and
uh i know i did and unfortunately you've
learned the hard way through some big
consequences so
the bigger the area that you have you
know parking lot
make sure that you have permission from
the parking lot that you're in make sure
that it's shut down make sure that no
one can come walking in
he's tall at tulkey's
chrysair is a great name for a great
trick so basically
how do tricks get named the chrysler is
named after
uh christian soy did it first it's a big
cross and obviously
cross christ christian basically do a
trick first
you get to name it my mom you named lots
of tricks your mom name right
cliffhanger yeah the cliffhanger so to
name a trick you're supposed to actually
do it in competition first so when you
invent a trick
and then someone else is able to do it
in competition first they might take
an awesome trick name that you have and
turn into the militia twist
speaking for a friend alright dev d
richard's underscore photo how do
motocross pros get their numbers
i'm guessing they just choose them like
any other sport that is
partly true if you get a one or two
digit number that's your placing
yeah year before locals or wherever
you're going most of the time you run a
two digit number and then a hopefully a
one digit number
uh when you're getting better in your
local series and when you go to other
series
they already number one through you know
50 is already taken so generally you
pick a three digit number so you don't
run an x on it
and then your lifetime three digit
number generally you have some meaning
behind it and you've chosen it
my hero growing up was robbie rainard
and he turned pro
the fifth month of 1993. so he ran 593.
i chose my number because i turned pro
and you're allowed to turn pro when you
turn 16. so my 16th birthday
was october of 99 hence 199 drop to zero
and then i picked my number
129 based off of we got married 10 29
so i thought that would be be nice
thanks
it's also my birth date backwards but
tweak 96 at clb ktm
18. anyone know any way of stopping arm
pump with motocross
or just a way so it's not so bad i get
it badly motocross hashtag question
hashtag help hashtag
the more you ride the less arm pump
you'll get some people
are just have genetic where they pump up
more or your nerves when you're
scared and you get to a race everyone
just pumps up i mean to where you can't
even hold onto the grips
if you have um any kind of supplements
that are helping you pump
up to look better that's all bad for
motocross
at the end of the day if you just can't
get rid of it there is an arm pump
surgery
they cut the sheath completely away so
that their more blood can get in and out
so it doesn't just get held up in your
forearms
i did not because i did not
panic much and i love to ride my dirt
bike my hero robbie raynord
did so did kurt nichols so did a lot of
the other top guys
and in three years it scar tissue is
over and your arm pump will come back 10
times worse
however those three years you'll feel
awesome so
that's your call if you want to get it
every three years i wouldn't suggest it
but you won't have arm pump for a little
bit and that's the best option
temporary fix that we found samwell at
samwell
burt so if you do a rock solid which is
a motorcycle trick where
you grab the fender you let completely
go so you're flying behind the
motorcycle
through the timing beam at a motocross
world championship
would you get deducted a lap hashtag
mxgp you will probably get
fined as i've found that you're not
really supposed to do tricks during
races
there's a time and a place for that and
they feel like it's endangering the
other riders and you will get to talking
to
i've been threatened to be thrown out of
the ama many times but then i just won
ama ride of the year so i mean there's
there's that colin blasky at crime in
the city
asked me what's your favorite skate
trick well
my favorite trick is pretty much any
hand plant my most favorite of all
time though would have to be an android
invert
which explain i have no idea what that
is if you saw me do it you would know
grab with your front hand behind your
back
and behi below your front foot and then
you plant your back hand on the coping
of the ramp
and you go upside down and then you come
back in sounds fun
it's very fun i'll never know i always
really wanted to do a frontside 540 but
like a real
good legit one kind of like
shaun white and bucky lassic doing way
over the coping
i should really do that one day you
could probably do it higher than bucky
i don't know sorry bucky he's from
baltimore so yeah local
sean at sdmp zero
this heel and toe shifting get you
better
gas mileage when you're downshifting um
on pavement you generally put your heel
on the brake
and you blip the throttle to make sure
that your wheels
don't lose traction coming in and then
you can be full break without
locking up the wheels when you shift
down but you can still use the engine
braking so
no heel toe shifting actually gets you
horrible gas mileage but it does improve
your lap times
so there's that that's you i got nothing
you want a dog xoxo
nina ross how do you teach dogs how to
skateboard
actually how do you teach kids how to
skateboard lol i need help with both
i think it's probably a pretty similar
process i have not yet taught a dog how
to skateboard but
you basically just start small get them
on the board hold their hands get them
comfortable
moving dogs have hands the kids
you know what you should ask smagical
because
phil has goats and cats who skateboard
his cat is amazing
grimes rails yeah the hardest part about
teaching kid had a skateboard
is teaching them the patience
because they want to just get on the
board and go but it doesn't really work
that way it takes a lot of time and
coordination for them to even get to the
point of pushing
once they do start pushing a little and
they need to start turning
we call them tic tacs where you put
pressure on the back and you just kind
of
tic tac the front back and forth you do
that on carpet
that works good so they don't zing out
but they can start learning board
control
you can also learn how to ollie or do
kickflips and things like that on carpet
as well so you're not rolling away
thank you guys for the questions landon
castle it's an honor
thank you sir appreciate you uh writing
in and giving me
a hard time with guest stuff